je vous laisse deviner de quoi on va
parler aujourd'hui voilà c'est là un
indice ce lundi un petit peu mais pas
trop
aujourd'hui on est au lancement
international mondial world wide de la
série p 32 huawei et comme d'habitude à
là où la reconnaissez ils sont là ils
sont beaux ils sont chauds on va il
s'installe et on va se poser
tranquillement que vale parce que ça dit
on va enfin marine la lourde
[Musique]
nous voilà la conférence de lancement
des p 30 p 30 petre en propre à m gros
gros gros show la lumière pour qu'on
puisse me voir
ça va être cool grosse nouveauté il va y
avoir des goûts vos annonces en et ça va
être franchement cool on est ici paris
porte de versailles vous propose ses
cours en trois ans parce qu'il ya et à
mon avis on va se régaler
[Musique]
le temps qu'on se contente au nouveau
smartphone belle côte en verra beaucoup
beaucoup de choses sur l'appareil photo
on verra ce que ça donne parce qu'ils
ont énormément montrer des choses est ce
que ces choses sont vraies est ce que ça
sera probant est ce qu'on pourra l'aider
montrer en vidéo ça sera là que ça et si
ses propos sont tout ce qu'on pense pas
ah c'est pas mal franchement ils ont
montré cette envie que ça a vraiment
vraiment de la gueule donc là faudra
vraiment de chez kessa niveau caméra ça
m'en excuse dias les comparaisons que
pendant la conf n'était pas vraiment
intéressant c'est comparer un téléphone
15m x 10 un téléphone qui a pas eu
fraude il va vraiment les gîtes sont
prêts
le téléphone en fait à part la caméra
pas grand chose qu'ils encourent j'ai pu
voir des potes le week-end dernier avant
qu'ils soient ressentez trottoir à la
caméra la patrie marche vraiment
vraiment vraiment très bien voilà il n'y
a aucun doute là dessus c'est l'antienne
la recherche
mais à part la caméra moyens j'ai le
cristal le hall au bleu foncé violer
c'est sympa rehaussé beauté jaloux visé
malouda a un clanwar 6 tionne danois
telle arnaque
ils ont vu à sortir et que tu avais qu
ils sont payés le noir à jus d'orange
chevret et non pas quelques couleurs
comme lui c'est quoi encore on a tous
blanc bleuté à tous les neiges croix
ouais c'est ça il a fallu le président
le français
les toilettes porte de versailles c'est
bien mais pas très pratique à regarder
voilà j'en ai mis deux partout alors
rassurez vous c'est juste quand j'ai
voulu me levais libre c'était même très
propre ça monte il y sommes écoute ça
ouais tig et mais ça tu en as pensé quoi
toi de ces de ses produits
ben qu'ils ont l'air d'être des énormes
tueur en photographie ouais
après tout le reste vous je me suis pas
trop attardé peut-être sylla l'espèce de
patrie portable qui a l'air sûr booster
voix grave
l'une est grosse énigme qu'on aille voir
la mémoire est assez positive à ce que
sa cote est là et les écouteurs c'est
pas ma came du tout donc je n'ai pas
prêté attendre sur ok mais
mais clairement gros photophone grosse
batterie flagship stephen black sheep
killer même j'ai réfléchi tout court fat
exactement
oh
hormis dans la zone d'expérience je vous
avais du p 30 aux avait dupé 30 vous a
poussée des lunettes qui nous montrait
des lunettes connectés qui nous servir
passer des coups de fil qui sont juste
derrière
en partenariat avec john coleman sera
donc ça m'apparaît probablement
ultérieurement de la nouvelle smart
watch est également enfin il ya pas mal
de producteurs et dans l'écosystème de
renvoyer sur tout ce qui est vraiment
intéressant c'est de voir la qualité
photo et vidéo parce que autant le b20
ep20 pro souper ma première est
excellent en photographie en vidéo c'est
un petit peu moi ça
là on va voir effectivement ce que ça
donne cette année est ce que ces
smartphones sont excellents en vidéo je
ne doute absolument pas qu'en photo ils
sont excellents nous a montré du zoom x
50 ça a l'air juste hallucinant
numérique alors après avoir vraiment sur
le poids de l'état et si elle n'a rien
de garder quelque chose quand même de
suffisamment clair comment boss l
intelligence artificielle derrière ça on
va le tester et très très prochainement
il fait beau il fait chaud se sent bon
le sable chaud du monde de partout ça
parle toutes les langues et c'est
vraiment ce que j'adore danser dans ses
lancements dites moi ce que vous en
pensez en commentaire juste avant qu'on
se fasse un petit renne boxing et une
prise en main rapide it moi comment vous
trouvez
est ce que voulaient se trouvait
intéressant cp 38,33 qu'est ce que vous
pensez de la proposition de huawei cette
année ça vous botte oui non vous marquez
tout ça dans les commentaires
vous voulez montrer ton frère ouais
enfin on pousse à la seule ensemble sur
donc regarde si tablettes
enfin c'est un peu fondu mais je suis
pas ta vu qu'il ya une année
non braguette mais non braguette je sais
pas ce qu'ils ont caché derrière cet
énorme braga ah oui g
il ya des logiques esthétiques sur cet
événement qui me semble très étrange
tu vois juste derrière on est dans les
espèces de jours
deux plans d'un coup exotiques crevaison
mutante ouest
bien sûr ce forum on est emmené dans la
thématique
[Musique]
je demandais ce que ce soit hommes à
première vue ça peut être un peu bizarre
en réalité les autres un de jouer tout
simplement grâce à la réalité augmentée
et nouveau p 30 et trompe cros voilà
comme ça encore mécontents de ce qui
fonctionne en mode p 30 petrof procès
aujourd'hui le grand jour le grand
lancement international c'est
franchement cool
le smartphone est juste là il est bon
alors celui-là c'est pas le mien c'est
celui de mon pote les audi café du dic
on va ouvrir dans quelques instants le
nôtre qu'on voit et ce qui est vraiment
cool avec ses smartphones c'est
effectivement ou et qui continue à
proposer encore quelque chose
d'intéressant en termes de photos et
vidéo la photo est dernière avec le b20
b 20 pro surtout médecin pro et sont
allés très loin ils vont encore plus
loin avec le p 30 gros et notamment au
niveau de la photo mais aussi de la
vidéo des propositions qui as
intéressante et j'ai quelques spectres
je vous donne très rapidement ce que la
grosse différence que vous avez entre le
p 30 et le paie 30 procès au niveau du
design le paie 30 est un peu plus droit
avec le p 33 vous avez des bords
incurvés donne un design un petit peu
plus sexy un peu plus sympa le plus
classique un peu plus standard pour le p
vous avez ici ça vous avait déjà parlé
dans ma vidéo de rumeurs c'est
complètement place avec le smartphone
vous pouvez poser à plat pour faire vos
photos ça c'est cool ça vous évite
d'avoir un petit pied que vous aller
promener partout avec vous ça fait assez
pratique
d'autant plus que le vrai gros focus qui
fait là dessus c'est toute la partie
photo vous pouvez monter en biseau pour
les croyez moi c'est juste hallucinant à
409 1600 iso
je ne sais pas ce que vous allez signer
à 409 1600 iso probablement la lune les
nuits en tout cas ça valse de tester
très très très prochainement donc ce que
je vous invite à faire c'est à vous
abonner dès aujourd'hui comme ça vous
pourrez tout savoir sur le thème je
dirais exactement ce qu'il en est je lis
avec moi donc je fais plein de shoot
photo vidéo la nuit le jour
bien évidemment a toujours des écrans
oled sur le paie 30 ont un écran de 6,1
pouces 2340 par 1080 pixels son format
19 points 5/9 pour les deux en écran hd
dans les deux cas et sempé 30 ans un
cran de 6,47 pouces avec une résolution
d'autres 2340 par 1080 pixels
grosse performance des deux côtés kirill
giga de ram pour le p 30 8 gigas de ram
pour le p 30 pro 128 go de stockage pour
le p 30 128 giga 256 giga et 512 ya pour
le pétrole trop grosse batterie bien
évidemment sur p 30 une batterie de
trois mille six cent cinquante millions
terreur recharge rapide en usb type c
est sur le pétrole pointe des batteries
de 4200 millan période mais surtout ce
cadre est vraiment intéressant est
vraiment impressionnant c'est la
recharge rapide en une recharge rapide
40 watts qui nous permet de le recharger
en 30 minutes à 70 % et en gros en une
heure vous l'avez quasiment à 100% donc
ça s'appelle vraiment hyper intéressant
à côté de ça vous avez de la recharge
sans fil 15 watts
on n'a plus le temps mais ça peut être
cool si vous le posez au bureau par
exemple paf
il se recharge et puis bien évidemment
toujours la recharge l'inversé comme on
a eu partir du mail 20 pro de l'année
dernière là où le gros focus effet c'est
au niveau de la partie photo vidéo sont
forcément rentrer trop dans le côté un
peu de technique
est-ce qu'il faut vraiment retenir sur
ce p 30 procès que vous avez un trip
capte avoir un quadruple capteurs
première caméra de 40 mégapixels qui
ouvre à f 1.6 alors que sans le p 23
vous aviez un ouverture de f 1.8 donc
qui captent plus de lumière au moins
nous annonce 20 % de lumière en plus
capter un capteur qui a changé on est
sur un capteur air y/y b ont rossé le
red yellow guillaume blot et on ne
capterait a priori 40% plus de lumière 1
grâce à ce capteur à tester bien
évidemment ça je vous dirais lors des
phases de test ça peut être vraiment
cool on a également un capteur de 20
mégapixels est un ultra grand-angle qui
ouvre à f 2.2 pour faire aussi de la
macro jusqu'à 2.5 cm assez cool et
surtout au niveau du zoom un 8
mégapixels avec une ouverture de f 3
points 4 x 5 en optique x 10 en hybride
et x 50 on zoom digital alors on va voir
ce que ça dit en x 56 quand même on
récupère pas trop de bruit à mon avis ça
va être une usine à bout oui mais ça on
le verra prochainement lors des phases
de tests dont il indique tout de suite à
vous abonner comme ça vous saurez tout
bien évidemment on le paie 30 et moi
inspecté vous avez une caméra principale
de 40 mégapixels qui ouvre à f 1.8
objectif grand-angle de 16 mégapixels et
ouvre à f 2.2 puis un téléobjectif 8
méga pixels x 3 qui ouvre à f 2.4
si vous voulez aller plus loin en termes
de photos/vidéos aller au maximum des
capacités c'est le pétrole promet dans
l'absolu le pétrole sera franchement
d'excellentes photos grosse différence
entre le p 30
lp trompe cros et la prise jack qui est
conservée sur le pétrole alors
petro n'a absolument pas pour ceux qui
aiment écouter au casque qui vous aurez
du bluetooth 5.0 pour connecter votre
casque préféré le pétrin de proue est
certifié ip 68 tandis que le pet rente
est certifié ip 53 tout ça tombe bien
évidemment sur le m8 9.1 sur une
androïde 9 paille alors il a
effectivement la navigation par gestes
il ya pas mal de petites nouveautés mais
s'en va le voir lors des phases de tests
montreraient en détail ce qu'on peut
faire avec
pour la vidéo il ya pas mal de trucs
intéressants sur la faible luminosité
sur la stabilisation en fin et pas mal
de choses cool il ya aussi un nouveau
mode c'est le d'abeilles ou la bolivie
où vous avez un écran partagé
face à des montois également lors des
phases de test je trouve ça c'est cool à
l'avant sur le pétrole point vous avez
une caméra de 30 2 mégapixels sur la
photo vous avez aussi de la
stabilisation optique ça c'est cool
double carte sim soit une double carte
sim soit une carte sim et une carte
micro sd ce cas c'est intéressant c'est
que j'ai pas vu de smartphones
compatibles 5 g est-ce que la 5g
arrivera plus tard chez huawei ses
smartphones sont uniquement fait pour la
3g et la 4g priori pas de 5 g sur ce
modèle là et bien évidemment on voulait
brouillé grâce à un capteur d'empreintes
digitales situé sous l'écran entre
techno qui est assez intéressante au
niveau de l'audio vous avez des hauts
parleurs situé sous l'écran c'est l
acoustique display technology ça
effectivement regardera aussi ce que ça
donne lors des phases de test mais c'est
d'être assez prometteur et puis surtout
novateur donc on verra ça ensemble très
prochainement
qu'en est-il en termes de prix alors
qu'au niveau du p 30 vous avez une
version 6 g gadrat en plus 128 go de
stockage à 799 euros
dès qu'on arrive forcément sur le
pétrole procès là où les prix sont boyle
davantage
on est sur une version 8 gigas de ram
+109 chichi cas de stockage 1 999 euros
n'a pas encore franchi la barre
fatidique des 1000 euros mais on s'en
rapproche
un euro près sur une version 8 + 2 156
sont nés à 1099 euros et sur une version
8 + 500 12 giga de stockage à 1249 euros
j'ai eu un accessoire présenté galets
jolie coque notamment une belle coque
swarovski or on a une power banque de
12000 milliampères heures avec une
recharge 40 watts
on a eu des freebets like this écouteurs
on ait eu des montres connecter la watch
jti on a eu aussi des lunettes eyewear
qu'une collaboration avec john toll
monster bon sens on en parlera plus tard
intéressant parce que céder
lunettes qui se recharge en nfc qui
devrait a priori être disponible mois de
juin mois de juillet pour l'instant
qu'on n'est absolument pas le plus de ce
produit design voyez vous avez une toute
petite encoche petite encoche goutte
d'eau sur les deux modèles est ce qu'il
ya c'est intéressant
là c'est le p 30 probant légèrement
incurvé tout-petits bordure ça c'est
cool et voyez au niveau des caméras vous
avez trois caméras dont la fameuse
caméra tough qu'ils voient la paix 30
pro bon la boîte vous connaissez un
petit peu dans l'univers impétrantes de
huawei on voit qu'on a toujours le petit
logo leica quad caméra ça c'est plutôt
cool boîte sympa bon c'est simple c'est
sobre efficace
regardez-moi ça comme c'est beau petite
languette vient par là mon lapin on s'en
va seul ont regardé à l'intérieur de la
boîte qu'est ce qu'on a
hop donc classique de quoi up de quoi
ouvrir votre tiroir de cartes sim là on
est une petite coque à l'intérieur léo
tu tiens ouais super c'est beau utile
coop transparent ok why not
votre gros blocs de charge rapide super
charge avec ça vous allez recharger
vitesse grand v c'est cool on a quoi de
le petit câble usb usb cd écouteurs des
écouteurs usb c'est absolument
j'en mets partout je me crois chez moi
et là vous avez le smartphone not for
sale ça tombe bien c'était pas prévu
regardez-moi ça franchement se soumettre
petit bouton pour l'allumer bouton de
volume la caisse qu'on a la bande usb
c'est bien évidemment les tiroirs car
sync est juste là de ce côté là
absolument
j'aime bien ce côté profil et c'est
franchement très sympa petite encoche
goutte d'eau bon bah on connait déjà au
niveau du design petit menton et surtout
ce qui est cool c'est le côté ici vous
avez qui est incurvé
c'est très joli j'aime beaucoup j'aime
bien ce côté dégradé bleu bleu un peu le
violine il ya eu pas mal de propositions
très sympa cette année de la part de
huawei on en reparle dans quelques jours
vous invite donc à rester connectés à
vous abonner parce que franchement ce
smartphone il est sympa je mets ma carte
sim ce soir il va y avoir plein de
choses à dire dessus
alors après quand vous avez un
smartphone comme ça dans les mains il
faut le protéger je suis à peine de le
récupérer donc je vais faire gaffe pour
ça je suis bien évidemment déjà équipés
j'avais tout prévu j'ai ma petite toque
rhinochill donc je vais prendre mon
crash garde voilà je le prends je vais
le mettre
c'est incroyable le smartphone n'était
même pas annoncé que j'avais déjà tout
on n'arrête pas le progrès mais on gagne
je mets mon petit crash garde au moins
comme ça a minima salle protège conseil
franchement vous aussi de protéger vos
smartphones crash garde coque protection
d'écran comme vous voulez je vous invite
à aller voir à tout et de série no shiga
des produits très sympa ici aux
intéresse j'ai un code promo de 10% en
bas dans la description pour les jeter
un petit coup d'oeil c'est tout pour
aujourd'hui parce que vous en pensez de
ces nouveaux smartphones de weppes et
30p 30 pro comment vous les trouvez est
ce que vous aimez au final la
proposition qui est faite par huawei est
ce que vous pensez que c'est des
smartphones qui pourrait potentiellement
vous intéressez vous marquez tout ça en
bas en commentaire on en discute
ensemble le test arrive dans quelques
jours ainsi qu'une surprise vous invite
à vous joindre sur instagram et sur
twitter comme ça vous saurez tout voilà
vous embrasse bisous les gars ya bientôt
5 pouces
elle s en fout.ce bleus